[Music]
all right let's take one more call let's
go to eli in albany new york what's up
eli
dr d thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it you got it brother what's
up man
uh it's an honor to talk to you thank
you so talk to you i was i was afraid
this was going to be eli manning he's
always trying to call in to get on the
show
like man i'm not going to talk to
another quarterback former quarterback
for nfl it can't let it go thank god
it's not it's you eli so cool what's up
um well i'm trying to decide whether i
should um split talking to my parents
all right so tell me about it
well um so my parents moved out of out
of the area from where i live a while
ago
and um
we've had a pretty turbulent
relationship you know through my teen
years and uh what is that growing up
what does that mean um
well my my parents split when i was a
young teen my father was uh
was
he had a hard time he was a bipolar i
think i mean he was never diagnosed but
you know
physically and and verbally abusive
and so my they separated and then i
tried to form a relationship with my dad
while they were separated when i moved
out and started my life they wound up
getting back together
i was the youngest of uh three
biological
and
they moved away
and it was always a little bit strange
it was a little bit off
you know my parents tend to really kind
of talk about themselves and what's
going on with themselves
and we're never really too concerned
about what's going on with us
and a couple years ago
i have uh
some adopted brothers and
one of my brothers passed away
and when we went to go see him
my parents were acting a little strange
about it and they wound up um
getting arrested for
for um
my the wrongful death of my brother
and they wound up going to to jail
while the court case was going on and
i wrote a couple letters but i never i
never mailed them i just
it was just so much it was so much i
i
when i spoke to my dad he wasn't honest
about what had happened so i
i didn't know what to do i wrote some
letters i never i never mailed them they
wrote some letters to me i never opened
them i still just have them put away and
when they came out of
when they came out of bail they wound up
settling and and doing you know parole
and
and all this stuff but it was what was
fractured got even worse
um they kind of felt betrayed by me
and so now my
my older two siblings don't speak to
them at all at all and have no problem
with it and i just feel so guilty like
uh
like i
i want to try and honor my parents and i
know you say always choose guilt over
resentment yeah or choose uh that's
right
you know i
every time i try i tried setting
boundaries like look let's not talk
about my siblings i'm calling you
because i want you to have relationship
with me and my children
but they don't have a relationship with
my children i tried putting them on the
phone to talk to my children and they
didn't really
care to
my mom still says my youngest daughter's
name and properly
and uh how old are you brother
i am 41.
did your parents
kill your younger brother
i
i believe that
they were older and neglect
that they
made mistakes
always would have wanted someone all of
your language brother
somehow
some
some way
you became the person who apologizes for
your parents
you're the person that makes sure that
the world knows i know but there's this
other thing i i know but that
that's been your job and it may have
been with your siblings
may have been with your community may
have been in your own home when dad was
raged out
and
you're explaining it away to brothers
whatever
i need you to hear me say eli
it's not your job
the stories that you're born into you're
born into some hard stories
about what love looks like about what
parents are supposed to look like
about what blame connection looks like
all those things
and you were told some crappy stories
too about what you were worth what your
job was all that stuff
and somehow over
happens to all of us
the stories you're born into the stories
you were told have become the stories
you tell yourself this is my job i've
got to do this i've got to do this i
have to do that
and eli let me free you from it brother
it's not your job
what i want you to do is to live in the
reality that your parents
um
they weren't hurting who you needed them
to be
can you own that
yes
can you say that i want you to say that
out loud
my parents
weren't what i needed them to be
and they continue to not be what i need
them to be
and they continue to not be what i need
them to be and i need you to sit in that
for a minute because that is reality
that's reality they don't care to even
you learn your daughter's name
they got out of jail
after neglectfully contributing to the
death of one of your brothers and blamed
you for your attitude
and somehow being the young brother
being the guy in the middle whatever the
thing is this is all compressed like a
like a vertebrae in your soul that this
is your responsibility and brother it's
not
tell me about your kids
i have four amazing kids how old are
they my oldest
12 ten
eight and six dude incredible man
boys girls
uh i have three girls and a boy my
oldest ah you're in it now oh my
yeah my oldest reminds me so much of of
my mom in the sense that she's creative
and she loves to make things and she
likes knit and cookie art and
i've always i've always felt like if i
just tried hard enough i could i could
make the connection for my kids
you can't
and i hate to be the guy that tells you
that here's the thing you know that but
i wanna also
high-five you man and i'd hug you if
you're standing here
because you've been working hard to find
any
way possible
to connect with two people
who should have connected with you from
day one and they didn't
and it's not your job not only is it not
your job you can't do it
it's like trying to plug uh out like a
like an extension cord into a wall if
there's no plug there man there's
nowhere for it to go
and you've been working so hard
and your kids became
um
they became your lifeline maybe if one
of my kids kind of like maybe that'll be
and again you're just grabbing different
extension cords trying to shove it in
the same wall there's no plug over there
man
your kids won the lottery getting you as
their dad do you hear me say that
yes
your childhood was hard wouldn't it
yes you're a tough new yorker
and you know what things you say out
loud and what things stay inside our
house i get that your childhood's hard
right
yeah you experienced some stuff
yeah yeah
yeah are your kids gonna experience any
of that nonsense
no no no we have a we have a happy home
i have a wonderful wife a great you know
great church community i've had people
step in
to to
be the older the other other people who
are like grandparents yes
now you got you got one last person
eli
and you have made your life's mission
making sure your wife is loved and
making sure those kids do not experience
anything like what you went through
and you've done the hard gut-wrenching
work of replacing parents who left you
spiritually and psychologically they
showed up
and i actually think there's some
there's some pretty compelling work that
suggests that's more damaging makes
things kids makes kids think they're
nuts they're crazy because mom and dad
are in the house but mom and dad are
violent her mom and dad are
nuts or they're loud or they neglectful
and it's easier if a kid just if
someone's separate sometimes that's a
whole other call though
you've made everybody else a priority my
brother and that is noble
and good and right
the last person you gotta deal with is
eli
is that guy worthy of love
yes
you don't believe that though man
i i feel
i feel like uh
i i everything you're saying is 100
spot-on irrational and yet there's this
part of me that feels like a failure
that i can't fix that that's it that's
it that's what i'm telling you you gotta
unhook from that
here's the you know the letter i want
you to write
is to seven-year-old eli
cuz that kid experienced
bull crap
and that eli is still trying to get mom
and dad to love him
and 41 year old eli has a lot bigger
body you're a lot hairier
you know you're not like a albany dude
like a big thick gold chain are you
uh yeah that's me oh my gosh
all right i'll give it to you so you're
just strutting through albany big chain
everything
seven-year-old eli still driving
still asking why don't they like me
yeah why won't he just sit down and say
i'm proud of you boy
why won't she just grab both sides of my
face and give me a grody kiss on my
forehead and say i love you eli why
won't they do that
and so
you're going to make yourself crazy
trying to solve that question because
it's not yours to solve go ahead brother
i'm sorry so one like they called like
they called for my birthday
uh this past birthday i had in october
to let me know
that they were splitting up
like on my birthday to tell me that i
mean do i just like not answer the phone
not answer texts put them on call block
i know
and how does it practically look you
tell me do i do i can do is there a
confrontation
you tell me
it sounds like your your older siblings
went with the no contact route
yes i don't want you all in our life
fair
that's the boundary they had to draw for
whatever reason and maybe they
experienced more nonsense more evil than
you did who knows
or they have whatever they didn't feel
like it was their responsibility to heal
um
dysfunctional
um
hurting older people they just said dude
we're gonna live our lives
if you can hear that get that kind of
phone call and roll your eyes and be
like cool happy birthday to y'all too
and you can hang up and smile and be
like my gosh
and move on great
if you can't don't
i'm not going to set your boundaries for
you is what i'm saying
yeah i don't believe in ghosting
i think there is something profound and
strong about being clear and simple
and direct
with
hey mom y'all don't even know my
daughter's name
y'all don't even visit you called to
tell me about your divorce on my
birthday
you all demonstrate
you have better things going on in your
life than me and my four incredible kids
y'all's lost not ours
and i wish you all the best
and that's the end of that conversation
no explaining no that
simple
clear facts are your friends appeared at
the end of the sentence
or
okay you don't say like and dude you
gotta grieve the bloody hell out of this
because you've never sat down and said
this might
like you've been propping up this myth
for so long
and you you thought that you thought the
myth was your responsibility to make
sure it all worked
yeah
it's not your responsibility is making
sure those four kids are loved your
responsibility is making sure your wife
is honored and loved your responsibility
is making sure you're loved
and that you're well and that you're
whole is that fair
yes you take care of your body get a
smaller chain brother for real and
but you know i mean like that's what you
were responsible for
yeah
and you're responsible for your own
healing
and that starts with stop stop
re-injuring yourself stop allowing
yourself to be cut and cut and cut and
cut
but i can't make your boundaries for you
my my recommendation is have you ever
sat down to ask your wife what her dream
boundary would be
um
my wife would prefer that i didn't talk
to my parents because whenever i do i
feel terrible after listen to your wife
that woman loves you
she chose you out of all the
knuckleheads with big chains walking up
and down the eastern seaboard she chose
you
yeah right and often yeah if we if we
find a good partner they they see our
blind spots better than we do
yeah absolutely
and there may come a time brother when
you've healed enough that you can enter
back into that
blizzard
of nonsense and be fine
but maybe it's just not right now maybe
you need a break for a couple years to
heal make sure you are on two solid feet
and then you are anchored into your new
community to your family to your friends
in that area
to the guys that come over and help you
fix your car at 10 o'clock after the
kids are in bed yeah you know what i
mean you know guys john it feels like i
i had
done that where i separated i went
through a program called subreddit
recovery i went through a lot of the
heal in the past
it's like it's like they have it's like
they know the back door codes no of me
you've kept a back door
open close it
don't give them that power eli they
don't have it they only have that power
because you keep handing it to them
you haven't changed the code
and that code changing that goes hard
and it might mean i'm blocking you from
everything or it might mean like you
know what i mean i don't have
if you don't
it can look any number of ways
but you keep you you just keep one line
in the water just in case they bite just
in case that one day they're gonna call
and be like what have we done
we want to meet our four miraculous
grandkids
and god almighty
of all the crap we put you through you
turned out to be the most amazing father
a dad that i never could have been to
you for you
and that conversation is not going to
happen
is that fair
yeah it's heartbreaking right that's the
hard part yeah that's that's the hard
part
they haven't seen my three of them
before my kids
never met them or hugged them
and that's not a statement about you
it's not a statement about your kids
it's a statement about them
they treated seven-year-old eli that way
because something was going on inside of
them not inside of eli
and your kids will never ever be that
validation for your parents my brother
ever
but i will
and your community will
and your wife will and your friends will
so going back to the very beginning of
this call i told you i needed you to say
out loud yo we're not there for me
you know we're not the parents that i
need i need you to sit in that grief
write another letter
don't nail it i don't need any reason to
mail it you're just trying to get it out
and get some perspective create some
distance between you and those feelings
that feel like you're gonna drown
get some perspective some distance there
write your parents a letter about your
four kids tell them what they're missing
our daughter she's an incredible artist
our son is a
he's got a small small gold chain but
he's moving up to the big one soon right
whatever it is don't ever mail it
but let it out
and then i do want you to write a letter
to your younger eli self and let that
boy off the hook man he needs to go play
seven-year-olds should be having fun
they should be having adventures doing
hard things
not trying to make sure their parents
don't hurt them not trying to make sure
their parents marriage stays together
not trying to make sure their parents
don't kill their younger brother
maybe one of the braver calls i've
received in a long time eli thank you so
much for having the courage to call i'm
grateful for you my brother
so grateful